today we will mainly focus on two main points
the first is practice theresa
may will be there for the first time
we
made a big offer as european union commissioner that
was rejected
and now we need clarity the
second thing i want to address i
syria ladies and
gentlemen we are stunned before a
human a human tragedy
who is responsible we know that
substitute the mass murderers of his own
people and of course putin you will need
to do however low motivation and
resources putin adds as a tense
as well as historians and diligence and subscription trap
will continue the sanctions  i still think it's
wrong and i
still don't want to
put
myself in the same row as putin i explain that the bomb attacks on
aleppo are also a crime
on the part of russia but
there are other people responsible and i
say to you again, please, they fall
not on the tactic  k in russia
again to declare the evil
empire the machine balance sheet the national
political ambitions they were in
social and where is what a video the
multinational communicative forms the
migros photo professionals dreamed of